dark souls 2 is a brilliant game it
takes into account the age of fire in
the age of dark and asks the question
why there are only two options and then
continues this idea by shutting out both
ages by making something else the main
plot of the story something that i will
explain throughout this video so without
further ado
let's get started so before we start
talking about the story we need to
address the game as a whole dark souls 2
requires a different mindset in order to
grasp what the game is trying to tell
you as we saw in dark souls 1 the game
relied heavily on the cycles of the
world to be the main plot it's all about
the age of fire in the age of dark and
what these cycles mean how they impact
the world and what age we'll choose when
we get to the end this means it also
relies heavily on the world itself dark
souls one was about our four lords how
they rose to power and what they did
with that power and what the state of
the world is because of said power as
such we play a very insignificant person
in regards to the overall world but dark
souls 2 isn't like that it's not about
the age of fire and the fate of the
world it's about one kingdom and how
this one kingdom handled its own cycle
wardram was important as it was the
first kingdom in the age of fire but
drang lake isn't important at all it's
just one of the hundreds of kingdoms
built on the same land and that's what
makes dark souls 2 so special it's the
insignificance of this game that makes
it so compelling because it isn't tied
down by the world's pantheon it uses
what dark souls 1 created as a way to
write its own story this game isn't
about the cycles it's about one small
part of the cycles the undead curse and
the quicker you realize that dark souls
2 is reshaping the proverbial mold that
is dark souls 1 the better this game
gets but to explain why we need to start
playing our opening cinematic shows our
character collapsing in a rainy forest
the narrator talks about the undead
curse and how it will infect your mind
how it has the ability to remove all
that you hold dear and all that you
remember with every minute the curse
gets worse and worse until you go hollow
as that is the fate for all undead but
this narrator speaks of a kingdom called
jerang lake and how we'll walk towards
its gate without ever knowing why we
know why we're here in drang lake as our
character is trying to find a cure for
the undead curse so they no longer feel
its effects but they're unsure of why
during lake specifically just as the
mind gravitates towards the smell of
food when hungry the mind of the undead
is drawn to souls and drang lake has
plenty of them to get to drain lake we
must cross a lake and enter a portal the
scene tries to portray this event as
some marvelous spectacle but that
couldn't be farther from the truth once
we cross this gate we're never coming
back we'll either be trapped here until
we cure the curse or go hollow the gate
is even surrounded by bright bugs which
are known to comfort the dead almost
like it's luring us to our deaths so for
one final time we gather our thoughts
and jump
on the other side of this portal is the
things betwixt a place stuck in limbo
that serves as a connection between
drang lake and the outside world like i
said we're stuck here for good inside
this limbo is a house of women three of
whom are fire keepers that are being
cared for by their housekeeper and
they're very honest about our arrival
you're finished
you'll go hollow
yes
you'll become one of them
hollows prey upon men
feast upon their souls
this is the fate of the cursed
[Laughter]
we aren't the first undead to walk
through their doors and we won't be the
last and all of them have met the same
fate so what makes us any different dark
souls 2 tries to set in this feeling of
hopelessness something that's very
consistent throughout the trilogy no one
truly believes we can accomplish our
goal but that's what makes the emerald
herald so wonderful she believes that we
can succeed in our goal and will help us
in any way that she can and by providing
us the means to level up she might be
the most helpful person in the game this
is why the level up ladies of the
franchise have always been seen in such
a positive light they don't discriminate
and they don't bother questioning if
what we're doing is working they have an
undying motivation to help us succeed
regardless of if there's something to
gain from it they're like a bright light
in a dark tunnel as all around them are
people who have given up i am solden
and like you
i lost everything
and now i'm here
the location they both reside in is
majula a small town on the outskirts of
draeng lake and it's the music displays
a feeling of peace a place that is void
of death a place that you can feel
comfortable in and in the world of dark
souls a place like that is more than
necessary i've always preferred when the
main hubs were seamlessly integrated
into the world something that would be
eventually lost with the series going
forward as it makes the world more
believable and in the case of bajula
without it you'd be missing this
beautiful scenery after taking in the
view we can speak to the emerald herald
who reveal our objective seek those
whose names are unutterable
the four endowed with immense souls
these four beings are known as the four
great ones the lost sinner the old iron
king the rotten and the dukes dear freya
just like before we have four beings
that need to be slain in order to
continue and just like dark souls 1 how
we go about killing them and in what
order we want to go in is entirely up to
us but one thing to point out though is
that the emerald herald isn't a fire
keeper at least she wasn't originally
her real name is shenalocht and she was
given this name by the dragons her
purpose was to break the undead curse
but seeing as there is thousands of
hollows in drang lake she clearly failed
her goal now is to just rest at majula
guiding the undead on their journey to
succeed king vendrick before we go
though i want to talk about the npcs i
think dark souls 2 really dropped the
ball when it came to these characters
many of them are extremely forgettable
and seem to only be placed in the worlds
that the player can be given a tangible
item rather than an engaging story
benhart of jugo is a good example as he
seems like a compelling character that
may have a memorable quest all for it to
crumble almost immediately his whole
questline revolves around his family
heirloom the giant teal sword resting on
his shoulder which you may recognize as
the moonlight greatsword except this one
is a fake it doesn't have the magical
properties of the original but benhart
believes that with enough strength he
can unlock its true power i would have
dropped this quest entirely if it wasn't
for the fact that he gives us the sword
at the end of it he provides a little to
no substance to the world and this goes
for a vast majority of characters we
meet there are over 40 npcs in this game
and about 90 of them provide the player
with a service and some of their
services are either outclassed or
completely useless lenigrest is the
majula blacksmith but the player may
find mcduff another blacksmith except
macduff can do everything lenograss can
do but with the added bonus of being
able to infuse weapons and gevlon is a
lonely merchant who only sells five
items four of which are poison he also
has three set locations so in order to
purchase his services you'll need to go
out of your way to find him and that's
if you really want poison equipment
there's just so much clutter as half
these characters could literally just
combine into one general goods merchant
thankfully it's not all bad lucatiel has
a wonderful questline as she shows us
the horrific reality that is the undead
curse she was a warrior of mira but now
she barely remembers who she is by the
time we get to the end of her questline
she's practically pleading for us to
remember her name as she may not
remember it herself it's unclear why she
came to draeng lake in the first place
but given that her brother aslutil will
invade us only a few feet from her final
location it's possible that she was
looking for him but now both of them
have succumbed to the curse's affliction
never truly knowing what happened to the
other thankfully lucatiel isn't the only
character of note in this game as the
feud between creighton and paige and the
peaceful conversations with vengara were
fantastic being able to take the role of
a detective and truly uncover which one
is telling the truth and then choosing a
side before one prevails was a great
investigation and the fact that a
talking head can get me to listen to his
life's story as he thinks about his past
life and how much he despises it shows
me that this game has some wonderful
stories that are just waiting to be
uncovered you just have to weed through
the dozens of merchants in order to find
them getting back on track we're still
on the hunt for the four great ones once
again this is similar to dark souls 1
but instead of ringing the bells of
awakening and then finding the lord
souls we just have to find the souls
already if you remember from that video
on dark souls 1 i said that the bells of
awakening section was a bit slow as not
much in terms of plot was happening it
wasn't until we rang them that the story
really started to take off well in dark
souls 2 it's the same unless you look at
the bigger picture before we get to the
four great ones there are a lot of other
areas we need to go through first for
example to get to the lost center we
need to go through majula to hayde's
tower of flame to no man's wharf through
the lost bastille and then to sinner's
rise where the boss is located all of
these locations will seem pointless and
if you just only do this boss fight it
will continue to feel like that it isn't
until later in the game when the climax
hits that things start to make sense no
man's wharf is a small port town and its
final boss is the flexile century the
century's job was to take as many undead
as they could fit on this boat and send
them to the lost bastille which is a
prison for the undead but this isn't the
only location to have lore regarding the
curse the huntsman's cops was a hunting
ground for the old iron king's men who
were tasked with killing any undead on
sight but as you would expect they too
also succumb to the curse next to this
area is the undead purgatory where a
chariot rider continually kills and
punishes the undead it's also possible
that these necromancers were purposely
stationed here this may imply that the
necromancers were used to resurrect the
undead so that they can be repeatedly
killed for entertainment like i said
this game does not focus on the cycles
of the world it's all about the curse
and this is only discovered once we get
further in the game but in the beginning
it may seem a bit overplayed that's why
it's required to have a different
mindset going into this game if you're
thinking about the cycles and this
game's lore will be boring and
repetitive but it's actually brilliant
once everything comes together as these
early areas are showing how different
rulers are reacting to the curse and
what their actions are as a result of it
and speaking of rulers one of them
happens to be one of the four great ones
the old iron king resides in the iron
keep but to get there we must pass
through the huntsman cops which we know
is the place the old iron king sent his
men to hunt the undead behind this
location is harvest valley and earthen
peak two areas that are coated in poison
thanks to one individual mytha the
baneful queen but this story is rather
tragic she wasn't originally like this
monster we see today she was a beautiful
queen but her drive to win her beloved's
heart back is what drove her to such
lengths myth's story though does have
some complications she has named both
queen and princess and that she loved a
prince and sought the king's affection
her story is very confusing because we
don't really understand whether she was
a queen and a princess or just one of
them but whoever this person was is
clear they did not love her and thus she
began using poison as a way to obtain
beauty but this came with its own set of
problems as the poison started turning
her into a snake-like monster and yet
while she was sulking around her room
day in and day out trying to win the
heart of a man she unknowingly already
succeeded in doing just that the
covetous demon was a human who loved
mytha and cherished her no matter what
form she took he tried to showcase his
love for her through gluttony but this
too would change him and turn him into
the monster we see today but despite his
change in appearance his love for the
queen never wavered behind the poisonous
swamp of earthen peak is the iron keep
home of the old iron king the old iron
king was a lord of very little power but
he would then eventually meet a knight
called sir elon who trained his soldiers
in the art of battle the old iron king
would then eventually build his kingdom
but doing so cost him almost all his
assets but one day he discovered an
iron-producing miracle this allowed him
to control iron to his heart's content
which led to the iron keep a giant
fortress made entirely of iron he
started creating soldiers made entirely
of iron and even a demon of fire called
the smelter demon this idea of creating
things a free will with only raw
materials is also related to the undead
chariot which of course was his creation
so he's quite familiar with this craft
eventually for whatever reason sir alone
would leave the iron keep and set out in
search of unknown lands after losing his
most trusted knight the iron king sought
the council of a man named agel he was
presumably a pyromancer due to his goal
of trying to give fire a will of its own
the two worked together to create the
aforementioned smelter demon but this
would bring disastrous consequences to
the keep the two never considered that
by giving something free will it has the
chance to turn on its creator and the
smelter demon did just that with one
swing it obliterated the iron king and
sent him into the lava it was born from
this act also caused the lava to take on
a much larger form and crash into the
iron keep consuming it in lava as we see
now but while the keeping its soldiers
were scrambling to higher ground
something else happened the iron king's
body came in contact with an old soul
the old king's soul to those in the
present day he is known as the one who
shall not be named but for us
we know him as gwyn when killed the old
iron king will drop the iron king's soul
but it's only on new game plus that we
uncover the truth that the old iron king
has come to possess the very soul that
gwyn possessed all those years ago but
the old iron king isn't the only one
each of our four great ones has come in
contact with a soul that belonged to a
notable character from the past game but
not only did it give them strength it
may have also carried with it the
emotions of those it belonged to both
gwyn and the old iron king share a theme
of power gwyn wanted to keep his
god-like power and as such took multiple
steps in order to achieve that like
linking the first flame branding
humanity with the dark side and tossing
things he felt could threaten the rule
into the painted world of ariamus and
while his feelings weren't as fierce as
gwyn's the old iron king also desired
power he wanted to ensure a protected
and impenetrable kingdom while also
relishing in the power that comes of
being a king so he used his power to
create a giant kingdom with skilled
knights and dozens of monstrous
creatures made from iron and then
displayed his power by tormenting the
undead for sport and torturing them
endlessly simply because he could but
while the iron king tortured undead
against their will there was one person
whose torture was self-imposed located
in the center's rise underneath the lost
bastille is a prisoner who willingly
imprisoned themselves for the sins of
their past according to shalakhar
majula's resident feline her sin was
that she tried to light the first flame
but the key word is light implying that
it had already gone out so how would
this be considered a sin if anything it
would be the opposite sadly we never
truly know what any of it means one
thing we do know is whose soul she
possesses before the boss fight starts a
bug crawls into her eye specifically a
chaos bug the same one from lost izalith
she is in possession of the witch of
izalit's soul we know that these bugs
have mind controlling capabilities as
evidenced by the bad ending of solaire's
questline so it's possible that the lost
sinner intended to let us into her cell
until the chaos bug felt threatened but
that still doesn't answer the question
regarding her self-imprisonment maybe
she wanted to keep the chaos bug and in
turn her from escaping as this crazed
version of the law center could have run
rampant and slaughter dozens of people
or maybe she's somehow feeling the
emotions of izalith who probably felt
immense guilt for creating the bed of
chaos so maybe this feeling of guilt is
being transferred over to the lost
center without her knowing to this day
it's still a mystery but a very
compelling one at that the witch of
izalith had a desire to create life
which is why she wanted to make a new
first flame but she wasn't the only one
who had desires but that being's legacy
may have created even more devastation
than intended the duke's dear freya is a
spider who is in possession of seath's
soul but seath's feelings and desires
are able to engulf those who come in
contact with it freya's soul talks about
a writhing ruin and how this ancient
thing casts a shadow over the land and
that at some point in its life it came
in contact with a solitary insect but
grew its power feasting on the wealth of
twisted souls found within the land if
we defeat freyja we can enter the lord's
private chambers which houses the duke
of seldora himself and a cage that
presumably belonged to freyja the
writing ruin was created from seath's
intense feeling of want he searched
endlessly for a way to be immortal even
when he was plagued by insanity and it's
because of how powerful his desires were
that they seemed to linger on past his
death the writhing ruin would go on to
possess others in an attempt to obtain
something as he possessed a being that
turned man scorpion tark and his wife
into half-human creatures it has this
insatiable urge to achieve something
what that something is will depend on
the individual seath wanted immortality
and freyja may have just wanted strength
or power regardless this writhing ruin
will presumably seek something until it
doesn't for eternity and ruin many lives
in the process it's obvious by now that
there seems to be a parallel between our
old cast and our new ones in regards to
their feelings and emotions whether they
receive these similar feelings when they
came in contact with the old souls or
the souls were attracted to them because
of their feelings is unknown but our old
friends legacies continue to bring
disaster even after their death but for
one of them that may not be the case our
final great one is the rotten in majula
there is a giant pit and assuming you
can get down there without dying you'll
arrive at the grave of saints a catacomb
that used to be a burial site before it
was overrun by rats i was admittedly a
bit confused running through here as i
thought this was some ongoing joke i
wasn't aware of as there's a literal rat
talking to me calling me his servant in
the most serious tone possible it's
pretty pointless and it's best if we
ignore it and moved on but sadly we
won't be doing much moving as much as we
will be falling dark souls 2 somehow
managed to surpass blighttown and
quality by making the gutter a darker
version of blighttown all while being
poisoned thanks to these statues just
like blighttown the lore is quite
similar as these are the citizens of
various kingdoms that were tossed away
out of sight from the rest of the world
after the gutter is the black gulch the
home of the rotten the rotten possesses
the soul of nito but instead of their
emotions being similar it seems to just
be their appearance nido was an
amalgamation of skeletons and the rotten
is an amalgamation of dead bodies but
whereas nido was hell-bent on
administering death throughout the world
the rotten seems to sort of embrace or
comfort it these statues might possibly
be the people who have died down here in
the pits he might be trying to comfort
these hollows in their new life and
these statues seem to be a showcasing of
his feelings towards his new community
what is rather odd though is that these
statues in the boss room don't shoot
poison at us so it's possible that they
weren't meant to shoot poison originally
and it's because of this poisonous rot
that has taken over the pits that
they're allowed to do so through a
discussion about the great ones you
obviously notice the connections between
our old and new cast of characters but
you may have also noticed the lack of
lore there is a lot of information that
is either completely unclear or only
given some amount of weight thanks to
the abundance of theories from the
community dark souls 2 is both the most
understood and most confusing game
within the trilogy it just depends on
what answers you're looking for however
i feel like i'm content with this one
thing that bothered me about dark souls
1 as we discussed before is that i left
some of these boss arenas with more
questions and answers i wanted to know
who the four kings of new londo were and
how they rose to power i also wanted to
know more about nito and his role in the
world after the war with the dragons and
while i definitely have similar
questions regarding some of our great
ones i left majority of these areas
feeling complete like i had learned what
needed to be learned and i uncovered the
real story and that's the benefit of
creating something like dark souls 2 we
don't really need to know what these
great ones did and how they shaped the
fate of the world because they didn't
despite how important many of the
characters in this game may seem at the
end of the day they're just another
kingdom in a long line of other kingdoms
no one is going to remember them and no
one is going to care about them that is
why i feel satisfied when leaving the
black culture sinner's rise i've
uncovered enough lore to get a generous
picture of their life with a few holes
just big enough for me to make some
solid theories with all four great ones
slain we can now go to drangleic castle
or
can we
this is aldia the brother of king
vendrick and the scholar of the first
sin aldia's story is very unclear at the
moment but we'll eventually learn more
about him later once we enter drangleic
castle we'll see this phantom by the
name of weliger he's a sort of lore dump
which admittedly might not be the best
way to handle this information but given
the nature of these games where you can
go a whole play through without really
knowing anything maybe it's necessary
regardless welliger shares with us some
backstory on durang lake and vendrick
king vendrick conquered four great ones
and built a kingdom upon their very
souls he then met a lady named nashandra
who warned vendrick of another looming
threat these beings were known as giants
king vendrick would eventually cross the
seas and battle these giants completely
decimating their civilization as a
consolation prize he took most of them
prisoner and ran experiments on them
this is what led to the creation of the
golems these beings we see inside the
castle and with the golems he was able
to build drangleic castle later in the
game we'll acquire this item called the
ashen mist heart this allows us to peer
into the memories of some specific
beings most of these memories are from
dead giants we come across in the first
level these all showcase different
sections of dragon lake being overrun by
giants and one of them even shows us the
location of the giant lord we see the
destruction that they left during lake
castle in and we can also see how
outmatched the soldiers really were even
though they outnumber them three or four
to one they're getting decimated at
every turn but somehow they were able to
persevere considering there's no giants
in draen lake but i think the person
responsible for some of this victory is
us these memories operate like oolacile
from dark souls 1 where we go back in
time to alter the past and then go back
to the present this may tie into a
subtle hint very early in the game the
first boss in dark souls 2 is the last
giant whose boss soul description reads
the lord of the giants who had brought
wreck and ruin to the entire kingdom was
said to have been felt by an unknown
warrior his beaten and broken remains
were then dragged beneath the stronghold
where he was sealed away this random
giant soul references the giant lord and
also describes the exact condition this
giant is in meaning this giant is the
giant lord and that must mean the
unknown warrior was us this might
explain why he thrashes his arms around
trying to break free as he remembers us
and wants revenge this is the complete
backstory of drang lake which gives us
enough answers to our questions but
simultaneously gives us new questions we
want answers to such as the whereabouts
of nashandra well close to the top of
the castle is the queen herself the last
king of this land
king vendrick
as he was
called he found the strength to rule his
people
and when the undead were born
cursed
he found more strength to face them
but in the end he never took the true
throne
visit vendrick
we have no need for two rulers
so nashandra wants us to find king
vendrick as she says there is no need
for two rulers but she also mentions
that king vendrick never took the throne
she just casually says this statement as
if this isn't some huge revelation since
gwyn people have been rekindling the
flame but vendrick didn't but it doesn't
mean vendrick wants to bring about an
age of dark he doesn't want either this
is even more unheard of as no one has
even attempted to invoke a third
solution to the fading of the first
flame but to learn more we need to find
vendrick he resides in the undead crypt
but blocking our path is two bosses the
looking glass knight and veldistad the
royal aegis both of these fights were
fantastic both from the actual combat to
the design of the bosses i'm just upset
that it took this long for this feeling
to finally come to fruition i rambled
for quite a bit about the bosses in dark
souls 1. like how ornstein and smell
were fantastic and how i despise the bet
of chaos but i haven't found the right
time to talk about the bosses in dark
souls 2 as there really isn't much to
say most of them were pretty
underwhelming for the most part and this
is down to a few factors one was simply
over leveling since dark souls 2 has 32
bosses in the main game it's very easy
to miss some i didn't find the chariot
or old dragon's lair until much later
when i revisited those areas so i was a
bit over prepared for the boss fight
dark souls 1 had a really great way of
getting the player's progression while
also guiding them down a path which in
turn made every fight feel like a proper
match it wasn't a one-sided victory for
the most part there were a few
exceptions like gwyndolin and pinwheel
but they have very low health pool so
it's a bit hard to judge them the other
two reasons are just down to overall
enjoyment and the summons the majority
of the bosses in this game not only have
summitable npcs but multiple at that i
had two summons for the looking glass
knight and while the game does attempt
to balance this by adding more health we
all know the main strength of the
summons is to be an extra body for the
boss to hit which means less attention
on us and more time to get free hits in
i will admit this trivialized many
fights the smelter demon the rotten and
probably a few others were really easy
with summons but that comes to my next
issue to complete some of these npc
questlines we talked about earlier they
need to be summoned for bosses as
someone who's trying to get as much lore
as possible in one playthrough i needed
to continue these summons quest lines so
while i was gaining more progress with
the npcs it came at the cost of the
quality of the fights this makes me even
more disappointed as many of these quest
lines didn't even go anywhere so they
were just completely useless and wasted
my time some of the boss fights though
just sucked regardless i was pretty
disappointed with chariot fight even
though it was a cool idea i just wasn't
a big fan of it and this game's
obsession with gang fights is quite
insane the ruined sentinels and the
belfry gargoyles were just not
entertaining in the slightest ornstein
and small only worked because of how
different they were in regards to their
moveset and how the arena was designed
and the bell gargoyles were okay for the
most part since the second one didn't
come until halfway plus they used
different move sets the ruined sentinels
were the same enemy copied three times
with zero obstacles to separate them
minus the one platform you start on and
the belfry gargoyles got way out of hand
with close to three or four at the same
time in the same arena as the original
fight which is not that large and very
open i did manage to beat them on my own
so i was happy that i won but only
because i knew i'd never have to do that
fight again as for the four great ones
the old king was just awful even though
i had a summon with me his moves would
have been the same regardless and they
were almost too easy to evade the other
three were pretty good but nothing
spectacular they did provide some
intense moments but i did have to summon
lucatiel for two of them so i may have
missed some of that spectacle i will
recognize though that this entire
section is a very subjective take as a
boss's enjoyment largely depends on the
skill of the player and their build but
since this is all about my thoughts on
the game my opinion was that they were
pretty underwhelming for the most part
it felt like instead of focusing on
fewer bosses with unique engagements
they created more but at the cost of
their depth behind the looking last
night is the shrine of amana and the
aforementioned undead [ __ ] each of these
places were created specifically for the
dead both the milfonido and the finito
watch over these respective places in an
attempt to guide the undead to their
final destination both of these
creatures have interesting backstories
as they were created by the old dead one
who we know as nito both of them seem to
be a reincarnation of nido's soul as if
he created them we would have seen them
in dark souls 1 but maybe they didn't
plan that far ahead when making the
games regardless it is a nice detail and
finally gives us some actual story
regarding neato so i was more than happy
to listen to it it also continues to
reinforce the old one's soul
descriptions that mention how their
souls still hold power over the land as
the power of nito and his obsession with
all things death are still utilized to
this day as for what they specifically
do it seems like the milfenido enchant
or comfort the dead via song as their
singing can be heard throughout the
level and the finito are grave wardens
who watch over the dead both of these
groups seem to revolve around comforting
the dead so maybe nito was a lot more
like the rotten than i had initially
thought at the very end of the crypt is
velvet's dad and while the boss fight
was great what really piqued my
attention was his soul and the items
acquired from that soul firstly his soul
is a dark purple and black color this is
the same as the dlc bosses from dark
souls 1. i originally thought that this
was made to distinguish the dlc from the
main game but it wasn't until dark souls
2 that i realized that the soul's shape
has actual meaning this is an image of a
normal bossel in this game next is from
one of the great ones and the other is
of those affected by the darkness both
manus and the royal ages have the same
soul meaning they're both affected by
the darkness and that's due in part to
him being down here since vendrick
locked himself away in the crypt another
detail that is interesting about
veldested here is that his soul can buy
miracles specifically the sacred oath
miracle which is used by warriors who
once served the god of son so it seems
like the royal aegis belonged to the
same covenant as solaire however we can
see that this miracle has either been
warped or is unable to be casted as he
never actually uses this in the fight
and instead buffs himself with dark
magic for the showing how dark his soul
has become after the royal aegis we can
meet vendrick and if you expected some
grand entrance then you're playing the
wrong game
just like when the most powerful being
in the game's world is reduced to a
hollow and mindless state vendrick's
condition actually seems to be much
worse as gwen at least retains some of
his combat abilities but vendrick can
barely swing his sword if he choose to
fight him all is not lost though for our
king as if we return with the ashen
mistart we can peer into his memories
and be able to talk with vendrick prior
to his hollowing do you intend to link
the fire
then you must first take the throne
prove your worth
find the ancient crowns
seek adversity and they will be yours
vendrick tells us to seek the crowns
these crowns belong to three rulers and
also happen to be r3dlc these dlcs not
only provide us with additional lore
regarding other kingdoms but also what
caused these kingdoms to collapse when
we finish each dlc we can gain a crown
and after obtaining said crown we can
talk to vendrick for more dialogue some
of the dialogue is relevant later but a
common theme throughout his speeches is
the idea that we're given a choice all
throughout dark souls 1 we were told to
link the flame and that if we failed the
age of dark would arise and that would
be the end of the world but king
vendrick is more than content with you
making your own choice this goes back to
what we discussed before vendrick didn't
want an age of fire or an age of dark he
just wanted to find a way to break the
curse this also ties into his brother
aldia and some of his dialogue when we
meet him again
all men trust fully the ideal of life
but is this so wrong
the construction
aldia is definitely the most fascinating
character in this game like vendrick he
is completely aware that he is unable to
change the world in their current states
so he just observes and sees what
happens aldia says that the joy of life
is warm and splendid but it's a facade
as the undead curse will eventually come
back but because of that warmth that
life brings us are we intent on
shattering this illusion we live in and
spoiling this false life we have or are
we content with our lives and embrace
the warmth and pleasure that comes with
it knowing full well that it's a lie
aldia just like the game wants you to
actually make a choice and not blindly
follow what some random person will tell
us use your own experiences your own
knowledge and your own beliefs to come
to an answer the way this was crafted
was absolutely brilliant and it shows
how impressive the writing of this game
truly is but before we get to the dlc
and obtain the crowns we need to talk
about the rest of the content as to
actually get the ash and mist heart item
we need to travel to aldi's keep in the
dragon shrine both aldia and vendrick
sought to cure the curse but had
different methods of doing so vendrick
shunned the undead as he wanted them as
far away from the kingdom as possible
that's why he threw them in the undead
prison of lost bastille in here are
hundreds of undead including some
volatile variants as these were created
by aldia whereas vendrick shunned the
undead aldia embraced them as he felt
the key to breaking the curse was within
the undead themselves but he didn't
welcome them with open arms as they were
all subjected to his various experiments
but aldia went even further with these
tests and didn't just focus on the
undead but other species he even
recreated multiple dragons a race of
beings thought to be extinct by now
despite what their names imply though
both the guardian dragon and the ancient
dragon aren't actually dragons the
guardian dragon soul can allow us to
purchase the drake wing greatsword which
states that the drakes are likely
descendants of ancient dragons this
implies that this is actually a drake
and not a dragon furthermore we know the
dragons especially the original dragons
are gone as calamite was the last of the
ancient dragons this is still true as
the ancient dragon in dark souls 2 isn't
a dragon as it drops a soul of a giant
this thing used to be a giant and was
somehow configured by aldia through
rigorous experiments to look like an
ancient dragon to get the actual ancient
dragon soul we need to use the ash and
mist heart again but this time in
freyja's boss arena as it allows us to
see the memories of the dead dragon
hanging from the ceiling this memory
seems to show the original resting place
of this dragon before it somehow made it
down here there's not a whole lot to
learn from this place other than the
fact that these large broken structures
look similar to the ones outside aldia's
keep there's only one place in the world
that we know that has giant structures
like this it is my belief that this is
ash lake it might not be the entirety of
ash lake as we don't really know how far
these trees went but it seems to be at
least some part of it in regards to time
this is most likely during the war
between gwyn and the dragons ashleigh
existed back then but it wasn't the ash
lake that we're familiar with as if you
remember it was all grey before fire was
born so the memory was during the war
with the ancient dragons and the present
day location of aldia's keep is where
some part of ash lake used to be with
all the areas covered we can head to the
dlc and it's advised to finish all the
bosses and content you missed before
going which is why i retraced my steps
and discovered the locations of the dark
lurker and the old dragon slayer i
didn't really find their stories that
interesting but i figured i would cover
them before we continue the old dragon's
lair seems to be someone who is using
orenstein's armor as a way to uphold his
legacy as not only does ornstein have
other plans which we'll learn about in
dark souls 3. some have claimed that
this is a fragment of orenstein's old
soul that now possesses the armor which
would connect with the running theme of
old souls from the past games coming to
the present just like with the four
great ones as for the dark lurker
there's pretty much nothing we know
about this being at all their soul
states that they're a remnant of some
ancient dissipated being and the color
of their soul is not dark implying that
they weren't born or consumed by the
abyss like the royal aegis or manus they
also look very similar to these beings
in the undead crypt that spawn when the
bells are rung given the color of the
dark lurker's soul it's possible that
this being was actually here to fight
against the abyss similar to artorius
but there is very little evidence to
support this theory but now we can
officially start the dlc dark souls ii
eventually released with three
additional pieces of content the crown
of the sunken king the crown of the old
iron king and the crown of the ivory
king given the disjointed nature of
these dlc's they could be played in any
order as they don't contradict one
another but we'll just go on the order
of release the crown of the sunken king
starts near the shrine beside the
rotten's boss room and entering the
shrine will take us to shovel the
sanctum city upon entering we are
greeted by not only a gorgeous view of
the underground city but also a dragon
with a giant spear through its chest
this dragon is sin long ago a race of
people found sin sleeping in these caves
and because they had most likely never
seen a dragon before they worshiped him
as a god these people ended up building
a city around the dragon with the rulers
of the kingdom being the sunken king and
his queen elana but something happened a
leader by the name of sir yorg found the
underground city and mounted a siege
against its inhabitants with the
intention of slaying the dragon they
were guarding sir jorg and his knights
believed that killing dragons was a way
to obtain a true understanding of life
so they hunted it down after making it
past all their defenses sir yorg was
face to face with sin himself and that
giant spear in his chest was from him
but clearly sin lived this wound and
that's because upon awakening from his
slumber he released a giant cloud of
poison that coated the entire city that
may also explain why the black gulch is
covered in this poisonous green liquid
since it's right next to the city but
there's no way to confirm before we
fight sin though we have to fight alana
so somehow despite the poison and the
attack from sir york she managed to live
well this might be due to her true form
according to her apostle and weapon we
can piece together that when the abyss
dissipated it was broken into fragments
and eventually these fragments came to
create a life meaning that elana is the
daughter of manus the reason the abyss
was broken was that the chosen undead
defeated manus back in dark souls 1 and
since he was called the father of the
abyss that would make ilana his daughter
clearly she poses a threat to more than
just shalva so we need to put her down
after her death is when we gain access
to sin as a final fight sin wasn't too
bad his unique mechanic where the poison
from his breath can break the durability
of your weapon which could possibly kill
the entire run if you're not careful the
only issue is that this seems to do an
insane amount of durability damage as my
banded axe with only 50 durability was
destroyed in a few hits i'm not entirely
sure if 50 is on the low end of
durability but going through all the
weapons i picked up across my whole
playthrough they were all between 40 and
70 so if anything i should be right in
the middle this wouldn't have been that
bad though if sin didn't act like the
guardian dragon and just stayed put for
more than a few seconds i think you
could see from the gameplay the amount
of chances i have to actually hit this
thing are extremely low i think what
makes shova so engrossing is the
location how do you possibly build a
giant civilization underground and for
what reason that's at least what i was
thinking when going into the dlc and
while i got my answer i wasn't entirely
satisfied with it one reason why is down
to dialogue is there is no npcs in this
dlc to talk or converse with we can't
gain any new information as all the
people that could have been npcs are now
just walking corpses given that sin
poisoned the whole city i wonder if
adding one npc at the very beginning of
the level who's the only survivor of the
attack would have been a better idea as
they could have provided the player with
additional information surrounding the
city such as why they worship the dragon
or how they managed to build all these
structures because in its current state
it feels a bit unfinished the crown of
the old iron king is our second dlc and
is of course based around the old iron
king from the main game this dlc takes
place in one of the largest towers he
erected called the broom tower to find
the crown we need to traverse the entire
tower all the way down to the bottom
which was incredibly tedious there were
a lot of traps and enemies that can be
very annoying to deal with but given
that the dlc seemed to want to spike up
the difficulty these additions kind of
made sense this tediousness also added
to the realism of the level as it takes
quite a long time to scale this entire
tower which is logical given its size
and the tower itself isn't just empty
space as all the space is being used for
some sort of purpose whether it's these
smaller guys carrying these giant
barrels or the vast amount of machinery
within the tower that was made to
produce iron it also fits in well with
the theme of the old iron king's
obsession with iron and how he gained a
lot of power from his production of iron
this dlc however adopts the same
storytelling as the sunken king and that
there are no npcs to talk to throughout
the entirety of its run time but what
makes the broom tower different from
shulva is that we already have numerous
levels and items filled with lore about
the iron king shovel was a completely
new area with zero reference to the main
story which is why i enjoyed it a bit
less regarding the npc interaction than
the broom tower even though the first
boss is technically another smelter
demon the real first boss is actually
the fume knife i have zero issues
regarding this fight i actually thought
it was perfect i've stated this many
times before but i prefer the fast
combat of the future from soft games as
opposed to the slower more methodical
nature of the early souls games it's not
that one is objectively better than the
other it's just a personal preference of
mine and just like with artorias and
manus the fume knight is another boss
that is slowly ramping up the speed of
its attacks they aren't incredibly fast
especially by modern souls game
standards where a 10-hit combo can be
finished within mere seconds but the
fume knight is definitely a far more
faster paced fight compared to the rest
of the game and this even continues with
the other boss in this dlc which is sir
elon it's just like the other boss
fights of this game where you have to
look at your health stamina and both
your and the boss's positioning all at
the same time and then calculate what to
do given the parameters except much
faster i understand this is not
everyone's cup of tea but it's most
definitely mine and even better the fume
knight has actual ties to a previous
character from the main game king
vendrick had two trusted knights who he
considered his left and right arm one
was vel'distat and the other was the
fume knight however the two clashed
which led to the fume knight's defeat
what's interesting is that if you defeat
the royal aegis purchase his helmet and
then wear it during the fight the few
night will start his second phase almost
immediately showing that he still has a
grudge against him as for the few night
himself he wandered the land in search
of power and eventually came across the
broom tower and met nadalya the bride of
ash nadalia would have been the queen of
the old iron king but she arrived at the
keep after he died she fell into a deep
despair because of this and ended up
separating her soul across the broom
tower inside these ashent idols which
caused the tower to be covered in this
thick black fog this fog has the power
to control those who wish to serve her
and kill those who refused when the few
net arrived instead of destroying the
fog like he could have done he actually
just opted to be consumed by it which is
why he sits at the bottom of broome
tower defending the remains of nadalya
since she has the ability to create this
black fog and her soul is colored in
darkness it is once again safe to assume
that she is another daughter of manus if
you're noticing a theme here then you're
catching on to the point of these dlcs
each one of them is centered around a
kingdom that a daughter of manus
inhabited and this goes for our final
dlc but before we leave the broom tower
there's a secret room we can discover
with sir elon's armor and by using the
ashen mistart we can go back in time to
when he was stationed at the tower this
leads to the boss fight we discussed
earlier but it's a memory and if we take
what we know about the memories and
apply it here we can discover even more
lore about sir elon if we assume that
the unknown warrior that best of the
giant lord is us since we went back in
time then we're also responsible for
killing sir elon so that statement i
said earlier about sir elon leaving to
search for new lands was possibly a lie
as it may have been told by the old iron
king so that his soldiers don't uncover
his true fate
which makes things a lot more sinister
than they seemed our third and final dlc
is the crown of the ivory king the ivory
king was the ruler of the kingdom elaim
lois upon entering we can see that it is
covered in snow and given that there
isn't any snow in draen lake we must be
pretty far from the original kingdom as
we approach though we are told to leave
this voice tells us that the old chaos
still hungers and that we are forbidden
from entering clearly we're not gonna
listen and charge headfirst through the
front gate eventually we'll meet with
the first boss of the dlc ava this is
one of seven pets that the ivory king
kept in his kingdom each one seemed to
have a specific role in the kingdom as
ava was tasked with guarding the king's
child of dark this child of dark is
alsana and as you would expect she is
our third daughter of manus but her
story is a lot less destructive when
alsana was born she felt fear this is
because she was a manifestation of manus
fears all the daughters of the abyss are
a manifestation of something nadalia
seemed to be manus despair elana was
possibly a manifestation of manus wrath
and alsana was his fears but when alsana
was born the king managed to find her
and welcomed her into his kingdom he
provided the comfort she desperately
needed and was kind enough to not shun
her away even after he discovered her
true origins it's because of this
kindness that she stayed in lam lois and
continued to fulfill the ivory king's
wish which was to hold back the old
chaos the old chaos is the flame of
chaos the same one created by the witch
of izalith it's unknown when this was
discovered by the ivory king but once he
did find this ancient monstrosity him
and his fellow knights set out to
extinguish it but they were defeated as
none had come back alsana wants us to
defeat the old chaos so that we can
uphold the mission of the ivory king to
do this though we're going to need some
other knights of elaine lois as they are
absolutely necessary if you want the
fight to be possible once we're all set
we can jump down into the old chaos
again just like we did with lost izalith
and this boss is absolute perfection few
fights in the souls games actually get
better with summons and the ivory king
is one of them i felt like i actually
had to apply strategy to an encounter
which was the first time the series has
required me to do that i don't mean
strategy in the sense of reading the
boss's moves and making sure how to
punish and win as that's just baked into
the overall combat of the encounters but
i mean the actual decision making i had
to employ such as which enemy to attack
and when which was something i did not
expect i would be doing going into this
fight i was running around finding
knights who were outnumbered and
assisting them or if it was the opposite
side of the spectrum i would add myself
into the mix making the fight easier
this is almost necessary for the fight
as well since you're going to be doing
the most amount of damage compared to
all the other knights so your decision
in this fight will largely impact how
the second phase will go i'm not
entirely sure if the knights can die in
the first phase given they have an
obscene amount of health but if they can
it just further adds to my point having
two giant teams of warriors fighting
against one another is one of the
greatest things i've ever experienced
and is without a doubt the best fight
this game has to offer from the actual
fight to the layout of the arena which
is engulfed in the fire from the flame
of chaos it was just all perfect and
would have been such a great way to end
this trilogy of additional content but
never in my life have i seen a dlc do so
well all throughout the entirety of its
run time only to fumble at the finish
line the frigid outskirts is an optional
location that the player can discover
towards the end of the dlc and it is
awful it's not only painstakingly
difficult just from the design alone it
might actually be the worst level in any
souls game ever made the bonfire before
entering the coffin is the only bonfire
in the area meaning you have to go from
one end of the map to the other just to
get to the boss fight which is just two
more of the ivory king's pets their lore
is thankfully super basic and not
important at all as their job was just
to hunt exiles that were presumably sent
out of the kingdom and into the frigid
outskirts this area would not be nearly
as hard if the horses didn't keep
spawning every few feet not only wasting
your time but draining your estus in the
process making the boss fight that much
harder it's just an awful location and i
think the more that i talk about it the
closer i get to going insane so we're
just gonna cut it right here as a
complete package the dlcs were pretty
solid there were things in each that i
found a little unpleasant like the
method of storytelling or an entire area
but there was many things i liked about
the dlcs and due to this confliction i
can't say that together they're perfect
but they're nowhere near close to being
bad it's hard to judge though whether
this was an actual improvement over
artorius of the abyss considering that
was one dlc with half the content that
played out over half the time this is
also due to the souls game's business
model if people complain about anything
regarding the dlcs of the souls games
it's that they're too short rather than
too long whereas many games like to make
additional content with run times of up
to six to 20 hours dark souls is pretty
much content with two it never overstays
its welcome in fact it sometimes leaves
too early and doing this gives us less
time to learn about the dlcs in the
locations they reside in but as i said
at the top of the section as a complete
package they were pretty great with all
the crowns in our inventory we can
revisit vendrick who will now provide us
with some very important dialogue
the abyss once had form
but then dissipated
and yet traces of its existence endured
each fragment thirsting for power spread
dark with no relent
my dear chandra was one such fragment
so we now know the fourth and final
daughter of manus the chandra the queen
of drain lake the chandra is a
manifestation of manus feelings of power
and want she came to this land in order
to covet the first flame this explains
why vendrick was in the undead crypt
vendrick left the kingdom because he
discovered nashandra's true origins and
not only locked himself away in the
crypt which was guarded by one of his
loyal knights but he also hid his soul
as vendrick doesn't drop this upon his
death it's hidden behind a secret door
only accessible to those who are human
and nashandra never truly was that's why
she's been so adamant that we succeed
vendrick she figures that we'll blindly
follow her order so that we can clear
all the obstacles in her path because
once we finally get to the throne of
want and defeat the knights guarding it
she appears similar to the ivory king i
found this fight leagues better when the
summons were included mostly due to the
narrative aspect since both benhart and
vengarl were helped due to me so it's
only right that they return the favor
her boss design is impeccable and
continues to uphold the standard that
the final bosses of the game have but
not even nashandra is the actual final
boss
aldia is the actual final boss assuming
you fulfilled a few tasks along the way
which is just meeting him a few times in
specific locations and then specifically
killing vendrick before nashandra as a
final boss fight though it felt like a
bit of a letdown i think nashandra had
way more intensity and narrative weight
behind her aldi has been this ominous
figure that just shows up says a bunch
of [ __ ] and then leaves and now all of a
sudden i'm supposed to care that we're
fighting him i get why he's fighting us
he's supposed to test our might to see
if we're truly going to be the next
monarch of the throne of wand but that
doesn't make it right the same could be
said for nashandra given she makes an
appearance a whole two times in this
game but that seemed to be intentional
as the reveal of nashandra was supposed
to be this mysterious event which makes
this next part even more confusing as
the emerald herald can literally spoil
for us that nashandra will be coming for
us i completely missed her on the way
down so i never got to hear this which
ultimately made the impact of this
cutscene hit harder which begs the
question of why it was mentioned in the
first place i find it hard to believe
that many people miss nashandra at the
top of the castle so they're well aware
of who she is so just keep the mystery
hidden until the final moments it kills
the entire impact of the scene if we're
just told right before entering that
she's gonna fight us after the defeat of
the three bosses we can select our
ending and while this game does have two
endings what these endings represent is
rather interesting our first ending is
entering the throne of want this is sort
of like the kiln of the first flame just
a little bit different it allows us to
choose the fate of the world but we
never get to see our choice it is both
the age of fire and the age of dark
ending together it's never known what
our character chooses but that's the
part of the role play when it comes to
rpgs we make up the rest of the story
did our character choose fire did they
choose dark or did they do something
else and that something else is
following in the footsteps of vendrick
and aldia we leave the throne and search
for an answer to the undead curse we
don't know if we'll succeed but it's
worth a try anyway doing this is sort of
like operating a dig site yeah vendrick
and aldia spent decades digging trying
to find a solution and failed but now
thanks to them we know of a decade's
worth of methods that won't work
bringing us closer and closer to finding
a cure for the curse and that's the
beauty of the second ending it's not
only in perfect sync with the rest of
the game as it continues to make the
curse the main plot of the story but it
gives us an option that we as players
hadn't really considered up until this
point dark souls 1 did a phenomenal job
of grooming us into believing that there
were only two choices but dark souls 2
refutes this claim and as a third as a
final note dark souls 2 was a brilliant
game i went into this game with mild
expectations but was blown away by how
impressive the story was and how
surprisingly easy it was to grasp many
questions are still left unanswered and
will never be answered but i left this
game with an understanding of its story
its themes and what emotions it had
intended to invoke in me and that is
incredibly admirable but the world of
dark souls isn't over the fire of the
world will fade once more and yet
despite the impending doom of the age of
dark getting closer and closer no one
seems to care
but we'll talk about that in dark souls
3.
thank you all for watching today be sure
to like and subscribe if you're new i
can't wait to talk about dark souls 3
with all of you as i have a lot to say
about it so that interests you then be
sure to stick around to hold you over
though not only do i have other videos
on the other souls games but other
series as well as always thank you to my
returning viewers for coming back to
another video and take everyone
goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
you